Today's 1 Minute Monday is "Purpose".
Have a purpose! What are you doing this for?
If you're starting the business just trying to make money you're never going to make it.
It's not going to work. You're going to quit as soon as it gets hard.
You have to have a purpose!
If you look at the most successful, most famous entrepreneurs in the world,
they started their business for a reason.
They started their business to have an impact somewhere, to give back,
to make meaningful change. They have a purpose!
Until you discover what your purpose is and start living it,
you're never going to have success as an entrepreneur.
Focus on you purpose!
Believe!
For those of you who watched and liked the video, thumbs up below.
Let me know what you think, leave a comment, if you have a question
I'll make a video response for you.
Thank you so much and I'll see you soon!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community